and welcome everyone to the Tesla T
event does you know there's been a lot
of speculation as to what the you know
the D stands for yes well you'll notice
my pants have velcro seams the way they
may have mixed appeal and there's also a
great deal of speculation as to you know
what the something else was and I
learned a lot including things that I
didn't think we're physically possible
so let's go to the first D as you've
probably learned by the Internet's it's
impossible to keep anything private
these days the D stands for dual motor
so so let's let's bring up the side so
that you can see you've got a motor in
the front and a motor in the back
hence the the dual nature of it but you
know would it be greater than then sort
of seeing a slide is to show you the the
actual car so let's release the Titan
so okay we here we have the the chassis
and the drivetrain of the dual motor
Model S I've got the front drive unit
the rear drive unit and the thing that
makes this unique and special and sort
of better than or wheel drive in the
past is because you can dynamically
shift the power from front to rear at
the millisecond level so you can very
quickly adjust torque more than is is
possible really with the mechanically
linked system so all all-wheel drive
systems out there are just mechanically
linked with with a shaft so it's like
the coolant of being sort of analog
whereas this is this is a digital system
so it it with the system like this it's
it's inherently able to achieve better
road-holding than a mechanically linked
system that's just there with with a
single engine and it we were able to
actually improve almost everything about
the car which is it's a rare case that
you're able to do something like that so
the the acceleration gets a little
faster the top speed is higher and and
it's something that's that's that's I
think that is for the first time ever
the the range the efficiency actually
increases okay so as you as you probably
know with other or with with all-wheel
drive systems out there the that you get
less mileage it's less efficient to have
to have an all-wheel drive system but in
the case of the Model S because we're
able to have to drive units where we can
shift the power from from front to rear
and and constantly be at the optimal
efficiency point four for each motor
we're actually able to overcome the
penalty of the increased mass of the
motor so any any given motor engine has
a
power versus efficiency curve and the
default behavior of the car will be the
first priority of course will be
traction control road-holding
and then that the second will be
efficiency and then as soon as you punch
the accelerator it will just go to match
power efficiency obviously is less of a
concern in that situation but this is
this literally everything improves about
the car with dual motor this there's no
there's no sort of technical drawback in
this case so and we've also in the hot
in the highest power version the p85d
we've actually retained the larger rear
motor and added and added the
medium-sized motor to the front which
basically gives the car about half again
as much power as the p85 start pretty
good you know in the power front that's
probably a bunch of you have have those
cars but this this car is is nuts it's
like it's like taking off from a carrier
deck it's just bananas it's like having
your own personal roller coaster they
just use it any time so that I mean it's
it's really mind-blowing fact that the
target that we had for performance was
to try to meet one of the greatest that
the port the acceleration were the
greatest super cars of all time which is
the McLaren f1 and so we were able to
actually achieve at 3.2 seconds 0 to 60
yeah it's mad okay
in fact just just you know what we're
going to have an option the option
selection you'll be able to choose three
settings which is normal sport and
insane it will actually say insane is
drew so that that's a it's pretty
exciting we're really really proud of
what what our engineering team has been
able to accomplish it took a lot of
effort and I think we've got a technical
solution we can be really really proud
of and it's also one that will continue
to improve over time so as we will roll
out the initial cards with dual motor
but then we'll we'll keep updating the
software and firmware and improving for
exists that the torque vectoring and the
road-holding under various circumstances
it'll but it'll keep improving by
nuances over time all right so let's
move to the next there's something else
which so we've been able to accelerate
autopilot and and bring it bring it to
market faster than originally
anticipated in fact that what people
haven't quite realized is that all cars
produced for the past two weeks have the
autopilot Hardware so it's it's actually
in production in fact every car coming
off the line in tests at the factory has
the autopilot Hardware so let's look at
the first the various elements of how
we're doing autopilot it consists of a
synthesis of four different systems the
first is a forward-looking radar so that
that's scanning the cars in front of you
and it's quite long range so it's able
to see things at a long distance also
able to see through fog through snow
through sand through anything basically
alright moving on to the a the so we it
consists of four parts the first part is
the long-range radar which you can see
through basically anything and then the
next element is a camera with the image
recognition so
it's able to read stop signs distinguish
pedestrians look at traffic lights and
and also serve as a backup system to the
radar the third system is 360-degree a
long-range ultrasonic sonar so this this
this basically establishes a protective
cocoon around the vehicle and it will
attempt to make whatever the sort of
smart move is from a safety standpoint
looking at the ultrasonics now the good
thing that the ultrasonic is they can
see even soft objects so you can see a
sort of a small child or even a dog and
they can they're there if they're very
sensitive and they operate at all speeds
so they're able to do this from zero
miles an hour to 155 miles an hour and
so it'll detect if there's a car in your
blind spot if you've got a highway
barrier on one side if there's you know
something you might you know move into
in any any way possible and then the
final element is integrating that with
the navigation and to basically GPS
system and real-time traffic so we
integrate those four systems and the car
can do almost anything so we're able to
obviously do lane-keeping on freeways to
automatic cruise control active
emergency braking so that it'll break if
it sees any object that you're going to
collide with and it'll do it'll
self-park so you'll be automatic
parallel parking automatically going to
a garage in fact it when you'll get home
you actually be able to just step out of
the car and have it park itself in your
garage including it'll it'll open the
door and it'll go in and park itself
and then something something I'd like to
do which I think many of our engineers
will be hearing this in real time is
have the charge connect to plug itself
in like like an articulating like a sort
of a snake like Metal Gear Solid or
something yeah like just plug itself in
so that I think will probably do
something like that
so you can just get out of your card and
go plug itself in your garage and then
going a step further you you'll be able
to summon the car if you're in private
property because you have to be on
private property food you can actually
sum the car look the car will come to
wherever you are and it'll it'll it'll
use the ultrasonic sensors kind of like
a insect antenna because it can it can
detect even small soft objects with the
TL just with the ultrasonics and and
just it'll sort of slowly make its way
to you and then stop and be ready to go
it can actually go even a step beyond
that which is if you have a fuel
calendar turned on it'll it'll meet you
there okay and so if you if you're
getting ready to go to work for
something and it knows so you're going
to need to leave half an hour before
work you can say okay
I'd like it to just come out and have
the air conditioning done and everything
done your music playing everything's
just ready to go and we'll just come in
and be there so
very important point though in addition
to the census we you have to have
precise control so which we have an old
digital control system high precision
really low latency control system
starting with the motors obviously their
their electric motors they don't have
the latency and the sort of slow spool
up of gasoline engines then we go to the
break so we one of the big upgrades to
the car is an electromechanical braking
system so it's able it's just one of the
most advanced grading systems in the
world it's able to very precisely
control the amount of braking and also
get to to high braking levels very very
quickly instead of having the normal
vacuum assist system that this is this
is an electromechanical system and then
we've got the that that's combined with
an electric steering so it's electric
power steering so halt the whole the
whole system is sort of fully electric
digital control low latency this is all
really important to having a great
driving experience so the car is doing
things in it in a natural way alright
next one so this gives you a sense of
the new interface and you can actually
sort of see where cars or obstacles are
around the car on the on the instrument
panel so it'll actually show cars that
are either distance the car ahead of you
cars moving to the to the sides and
behind and and you can you can adjust
the sensitivity of the autopilot so do
you want to be in a sort of an
aggressive autopilot or you know less
aggressive and yeah so it'll warn you
with sort of it with initially a visual
warning if there's a potential collision
risk like so it'll turn to the object
red and then it'll give you an audible
warning if you don't see that and of
course it'll it will resist steering
into things that thinks are danger so
you can still overpower that the
steering but it's going to give you a
tactile feedback that you're probably
headed towards something that the car
thinks may be dangerous so that's that
that's what we have for you tonight but
I mean what my words are nothing
compared to the car so we've we've got a
whole bunch of cars ready for you to
take a test ride in and I think you're
really going to enjoy it this is like an
amusement park ride and just to sort of
tone it down you'll see what the car is
like with you know anywhere from three
to five people in it imagine if it was
only you it's that much it's a lot
faster so have a great evening and enjoy
the test drives